folks that we doing welcome to Good
Works tractors it's a chilly day to say
the least outside so I thought we'd do
something inside I just got
a new air compressor and I've got a
couple other of the California yeah
California air tools brand air
compressors as well and what I like
about them most you can't get them
locally at least that I've been able to
find but they're very quiet if you're
inside I just hate all that noise you
can hear the heater going right now in
the background probably and you just
well under compressor is way worse so if
the saw goes well and I bought all the
right stuff for it here on Amazon then
uh I'll turn it on at the end of this
and show you how quiet it is it's it's
pretty incredible this is this is the
biggest one that I bought but it still
uh well it says says on there somewhere
yeah oil free and ultra quiet so we'll
see what's all about just plugs into a
regular 110 outlet let's get to it here
here well actually a couple of things
too I wanted to point out
well I'm still getting moved in here so
everything's a mess I don't have all my
tools together but I saw this earlier I
want to show you I did get
I got a yank them rope like you guys
talked about back when we got the uh the
skid steer stuck so got this right here
haven't had to use it yet but I'm sure I
will sometime soon but got this big old
there's a fat rope I think I got one
that was rated for a lot of weight did
come with a couple of shackles here too
so
anyway that was your guy's suggestion
and I've got one other thing to show you
that I need a suggestion on because this
is super annoying here watch this let me
get this out of the way
I've got this little piece of paper
holding that drawer in but watch if you
just open it and want to close it again
it just starts to open back up that's
real Annoying none of the other drawers
do that
stay in place you know this one here
stays all the other ones stay
but not that top one that's real
Annoying how do I fix that
we'll put that back in there for now
yeah here we go all right folks thought
I'd tell you a little bit about this
thing uh while we're putting it together
again it's my third one I've got two of
the one horsepower units one that I
bought a lot well I bought both of them
a long time ago one for my house and one
for my shop and uh still using one at
the shop I got the other one at the barn
I'll probably end up bringing the
smaller one up here to the to the house
and leave this new bigger one out there
at the barn it'll be more useful out
there this is a 10 gallon tank on here
70 decibels two horsepower motor 125 psi
Max 5.3 CFM at 90 PSI that must be a
common readout I don't know so this
thing is well it's California air tools
but I don't want you to be misled there
on the box it says made in Mexico the
the motor itself says made in China
110 volt 15 amp so you can see we're
going to have it hooked up just a
regular outlet in our garage oh we're
going to do a sound test too at the end
and show you just how loud this thing is
or how quiet it is maybe depending on on
what way you want to go with it but the
manufacturer of the video too it looks
like maybe they found the noisiest air
compressor to compare it against but
that does give you a pretty good
sound comparison between something that
is pretty darn quiet versus something
that is like chattering and loud and
really annoying a few interesting points
that the manufacturers States they've
got an easy start valve allowing it for
easier startups using less starting amps
oil free pump allows it for use in a
variety of temperatures you know and
quotes cold starts and uneven terrain no
oil in the pump the easy start valve
releases a small amount of air from the
pump at startup to produce a no load
condition allowing the motor to spin
freely and again it is a pretty large
for its size at least 10 gallon steel
air tank I read a review on on this one
just because I wanted to make sure it
was similar to the other ones I have and
they didn't put this
I think it was just this
um little hose in here that made a big
difference on the the sound level
maybe they forgot to put the entire
filter on I can't remember what it was
but uh
regardless don't forget to do it
here we go
I think that's how that goes
was there a there was an unthreaded
space there must have been
all right five Ace
13.
maybe it's metric
real sloppy 17.
17.
it's fine now but boy that nut is oh was
spinning with it
that nut is not
oh that one's
must just be a real fine line at how
much you have to tighten it
careful not to over tighten
nope too tight
that other one seems to go freely I
don't know what
I'm doing here
still skidding a bit
better
but that
maybe it won't
it's literally gonna
it's gonna come it's gonna take itself
right off
all right I thought we did something
wrong on these uh casters you can see
skid marks here
no not that kind of skid marks but uh it
is not
freely moving I thought we were doing
something wrong
and we're not
says tighten firmly come on
I'm not over tightening that seemed to
make the condition worse
but if you don't tighten enough they
just the nut starts to spin right off
pretty quick
anyway I don't know maybe we've got to
add some grease on there
it didn't call for it but
but look that is it's not freely
spinning I'm pretty sure it's the same
casters on all my other ones too I don't
feel like that's going to loosen up with
time
I could be wrong that one
what the heck that one spins real nice
oh we got one out of two of them
working we'll just kind of lean it to
the side a little bit we need to move it
around folks we are proud to be
sponsored by rim guard Solutions a
liquid ballast weight it goes right
inside your tires completely hidden
we're big on safety on this channel
these tractors are just too light and
Tippy right out of the factory not only
is it going to help with safety keeping
those rear tires planted on the ground
it helps with loader efficiency and
traction too the benefits of rim guard
include being the heaviest all-natural
liquid ballast weight on the market it's
not going to corrode your rims like the
old calcium chloride it's not going to
freeze and it's available at over a
thousand dealers Nationwide find the
dealer near you at rimguardsolutions.com
well that just actually fits right down
in there
[Applause]
whoa
foreign
why doesn't that want to go on there
must be why they give you two
[Applause]
it's a little bit better
I don't think any of these are big
enough though
okay this thing it is off right now
oh and it came in listen to this
a little bit of air in there probably
because that's lighter for shipping that
way
there you go plug this in oh a little
bit closer
got that
get ready you ready Chris
okay
it's not that high pitched still have a
conversation in here instead of the
what's going on
that's pretty nice
this is louder though than my smaller
one I think
one horsepower this is a two horsepower
unit
a little bit bigger I think it's like 10
decibels louder
but that's pretty quiet I'm assuming you
can still hear me talking right now
what happens if I take this out oh
yeah
that is actually louder wow
[Music]
off
pull
oh it disconnects
and then you pop it out to
crush your regulator safety
see the pressure right now is
oh 40 50 60 65 ish no sorry oh that's
that's a 60 there
30 to 60.
so what it divided by
it's an interesting uh Dash sequence
so it goes up six pounds per 36 42 48 54
60.
that's natural
no anywho that's what that's at
pressure regulator
so this is the regulated air pressure
this is a tank
what you're putting out right here which
we're at
about 45 or a little bit over 40.
so you can turn that down
and then once you're using it or I guess
if you had enough pressure to go up
above here
you know this is way up here or maybe
way up here
you can still regulate it so it wasn't
too much coming out like if you're using
air tools
that kind of thing on off
foreign
so you're going to see this is a pretty
easy simple thing to put together we did
have some issues with the the Caster
wheel down there at the bottom
on one side I'm going to reach out to
them see if we can get a different one
the other one works just like it should
I
I don't think I'm doing anything wrong I
probably am but we did have to get I
bought a whole new uh hose kit and
fittings and and just some some basic
accessories for now until I get the
Barn's getting finished so I'm going to
get that all set up soon and I think
we'll probably get a few air tools to
keep out there as well but smaller units
I've had for I think three years maybe a
little bit longer and they've been
serving me well and in fact not too long
ago the guys at the shop just kind of
pointed out just how quiet that
compressor is out there so anyway
we'll see as long as they fix that that
wheel down there I'm probably going to
be another satisfied customer I keep
coming back to them I bought this one on
Amazon I'll put a link down there you
don't have to get the two horsepower
they make a lot smaller ones too but for
me the big selling point with these guys
is is quiet so I I hate the loud
chattery sound and uh this seems to fit
the bill so that'll wrap it up for us
today if there's anything else I should
know about this I'd love to learn
something new so leave a comment down
below and
if you got a better solution besides uh
our hunk of paper here
to keep that drawer closed
I would love to know about it now of
course we do sell and ship tractor
attachments all over the country so go
to goodworstrackers.com see what we have
for sale if you enjoyed today's video
I'd love to have you tag along hit that
subscribe button right down below I want
to thank you for taking time out of your
day to stop by and until next time stay
safe we'll see you soon
[Applause]
[Music]